[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here so i just
got done spending some time outside this
is a pretty exciting one and a little
bit of an exclusive
i spent some time here at the studio
with some of the new electric hummers
that are scheduled to come out as soon
as the earliest one i think is next year
2022
and they are wild so gm brought them out
here to the studio so definitely get
subscribed to the studio channel if you
want to see some of the
behind-the-scenes type stuff but these
are the only working electric hummers in
the world right now just these two
models right here so the one you've seen
in car shows and other videos that's
this one the one that was at lebron
james's house and that one video yeah
that's this one right here so you can
see there's two versions that they
brought here to the studio one is the
suv version and one is the pickup truck
version and holy smokes they are both
ridiculous with tons literal tons of
quirks and features but you know what
speaking of tons let me just start with
the obvious these trucks are huge okay
they're obviously very tall and they're
massive but the truck it's going to be
crazy to see these things on the road
soon because the truck version weighs
over 9 000 pounds 9 200 plus pounds i've
been told and it's still goes zero to 60
in three seconds which is like
fast sports car fast that's like
performance model three fast
that's actually terrifying so this is
going to be a dual or triple motor
config depending on which one you get
but with up to a thousand horsepower to
move that weight
but yeah i guess for a hummer it's it's
really not about that speed it just
happens to be capable of it from the
electric torque but it's more about how
much torque you can get and how much you
can tow
i don't know i'm not a hummer person but
i feel like that's going to be
fascinating seeing all the wild stuff
they've thrown into the truck to make
the electric version more enticing you
may have seen my video on the cyber
truck already that one's pretty wild and
then you may have also seen my recent
hands-on with the ford f-150 lightning
that's kind of like on the other side of
the spectrum this to me feels
kind of somewhere in between so just so
you have the context watching this these
are going to start with the dual motor
lowest end version around 80 000 so
pretty expensive but the ones they
brought out here are the the highest end
fully loaded like first edition or
edition one versions so now we're
talking like
twelve thousand
starting for that and up from there so
obviously much more expensive than the
other two trucks
but for that money
yeah you you definitely get a lot of
quirks first of all the total height and
clearance of both of these vehicles is
massive so not only is it over 9000
pounds but the center of gravity is very
high off the ground as you can tell but
you know it looks good on these trucks
they look very rugged and obviously they
have these huge wheels but the suv looks
pretty solid too very squat and wide but
still extremely solid and tough looking
the whole thing is so squat actually
that you may notice that you have
three windshield wipers because a single
windshield wiper would actually be too
tall while a smaller pair doesn't reach
the whole thing so right off the bat
that's something you don't see on pretty
much any other vehicle then up in front
of that you got a huge water sealed
power liftgate front trunk for the
hummer ev this is this has got to be the
biggest front lift gate i've ever seen
in person it's absolutely massive and
while it's not a super tall front trunk
it's definitely deep enough to fit some
serious luggage or storage which again
is awesome on something like a pickup
truck that not every pickup truck has i
was loving that on the f-150 lightning
too and speaking of electric vehicle
stuff check out these headlights so this
is what it'll look like when it's
sitting in a garage or at a charger
plugged in the front running lights are
actually multi-colored so they can
indicate exactly how much charge you
have left and move those blue dots
across the headlight area which is
pretty sick and they also can turn
orange for some pretty sweet regular
blinker animations too honestly i think
the headlights are actually my favorite
part of this truck but wait there's more
there's actually there's just a lot of
smaller truck stuff that you'd be
interested in if you're a hummer person
now i'm not claiming to be a hummer
expert this is the first time i've spent
significant time with a hummer but i
learned a lot about trucks from the
f-150 lightning and a lot of this stuff
is still pretty cool like there's a
tailgate that folds down in multiple
stages so it turns into a bench or a
step to get up into the trunk whatever
you want the back window also of both
the suv
and the truck can go down too so if you
want that full fresh airflow from front
to back that's pretty sweet and sitting
inside the interior is definitely it's
very industrial lots of rectangles and
h-shaped objects as they do it there is
a screen here playing demo animations
but also still plenty of buttons and
switches this is by no means the
minimalist type cyber truck and the best
one is probably the mode dial that lets
you switch between driving modes can
raise or lower the suspension on demand
and switch to crab walk mode if you want
to which lets you turn all the wheels in
the same direction and maneuver
diagonally which is wild oh and this
would also be a good time to mention
this whole thing is also a convertible
so the roof is removable it's in four
parts so you actually have to go around
to each corner and unhook two latches
and take the roof panels off and put
them
in the trunk or the front trunk or
wherever you want
but yeah then suddenly this hummer goes
from a military-looking vehicle to an
open-air recreational type thing with
the wind going through your hair
and this ultra wide windshield
other random quirks though there is tons
of storage as you've already seen but
not just in the back and the front trunk
but even
in the back seats or how about
underneath the back seats
or how about
inside the back seats i don't think this
is something i've ever seen before
then there's also cameras all around the
vehicle around the front around the
mirrors on the side but most interesting
to me is definitely the one in the
center of the spare tire on the back
it's great for your visibility
and i noticed there's a good amount of
uh pride in this truck like they're
clearly proud of having made it in the
usa and that explains the american flag
on the b pillar and they're proud of
that first moon landing which you know i
guess they're kind of associated with
since gm
made parts of the apollo 11 moon rover
but they're really proud they're proud
to the point where they have a
topographical map of the moon all over
the floor of this truck it's in the
front seats it's in the trunk and
specifically in the speakers on the door
which show the sea of tranquility and
actually there's a boot print right on
the spot where the first human feet were
set on the moon so they're really into
it the boot print is also on the left
side of the floor of the car where your
foot rests while you're driving so you
can kind of feel like an astronaut maybe
driving a version of a moonlander but
the one thing they seem the most proud
of is the hummer name
like just hummer ev
i wasn't originally looking for this but
as i walked around the vehicle and was
playing with things and poking it and
prodding and pointing a camera at it i
started realizing how many times i was
seeing the word hummer ev or just the
logo
carved into etched into the car
everywhere
so i ended up just counting after a
while and i think i got to
31
hummer ev logos
on this truck so let's see i mean you
just start with the hev on the front of
each door that's two then down on the
wheels there's a logo in the middle and
on the outside that's another one so
that's two more logos per wheel
plus one more on the rear spare since
there's none in the middle
then the entire headlights of course
spell out hummer ev that's one more
you've got two on the steering wheel one
at the top one at the bottom
then one more on the passenger side
dashboard then there's a logo under the
floor mats of both of the front seats by
your feet as you're sitting in it and
then another one between your feet in
the back seat and then another one in
the trunk both of the pickup truck and
the suv then there's two in the front
trunk one up in the top and then another
one at the bottom one on each seat so
that's four more then one on the
doorstep on each side and then one more
on the back and then finally one more on
each of the four toe hitches two on the
front and two on the back all say hummer
ev you'll never forget which car you're
in but overall
i i am just really fascinated by an
electric
hummer
it seems kind of like an oxymoron like i
imagine the typical hummer buyer doesn't
care too much about efficiency they
probably won't care about the 350 mile
max range that they're talking about or
the up to 350 kilowatt fast charging
which is very impressive for when
someday the infrastructure supports it
but uh i imagine they care more about
off-roading and
power and towing and capabilities and
things that other truck buyers are more
interested in and yeah check and check
cargo space that's another check
it's interesting it's interesting seeing
an electric hummer so now that you've
seen hummer ev i'm really curious what
you think feel free to let me know in
the comments below and if you've already
also watched the videos of ford f-150
lightning
and cyber truck maybe we'll get to spend
some time with the rivian soon but i'm
curious what your thoughts are on the
electric truck scene that is slowly
developing and i'm still very confident
that every year for the next 10 straight
years is going to be the most
interesting year yet for electric
vehicles so we're just getting started
this was fun to take a first look either
way that's been it thanks for watching
catch you soon in the next one
peace
[Music]